after wrapping up your press conference
you seen or you experienced for yourself
keeve
under air strike
do you think
this was a message i don't think i am so
important
to justify
the
use of this day for for that purpose one
of uh president zielenski's advisor
said on twitter that that was a postcard
from russia
there haven't been any attacks
having said so
i must say that i was obviously shocked
when i
was informed
that
two besides have
reached a target in kiev i was shocked
with that and
i think it's
very important
to spare this wonderful city kiev
is a city with an enormous historical
value it represents
everything for both ukrainians and
russians
and i hope that kids will be spared
before you you came here he was
wondering why you were going to moscow
my only objective is to rescue people
and contribute for peace
and obviously
with the enormous concern that the
government of ukraine has expressed
about the civilians trapped in
the steel plant in mario paul
it was absolutely central to find a way
to take them out
and the only place where i could try to
do it was going to moscow and talking to
president putin president zielenski
asked
wondered more than once why is russia
still on the security
council yes he brought up the but as you
know the security council
is defined in its composition by the
chart of the united nations and the
chartered united nations can only be
changed by a majority of two thirds in
the general assembly including the
positive vote of the five members of
security council are we anywhere close
for the two sides
to sit together to try to bring any sort
of ceasefire the iran was always kept
out of the political negotiations
to be fair to to be frank to you i
regret that that has happened that our
presence was considered not
useful
and
we are not part of the present political
negotiations but we are following them
with a lot of interest and hoping that
they will
solve the problem and that peace will
come back